[Music]
in liner liner news pass all five and
carry a good movie oh yes that's when he
started becoming serious that's what he
got more grounded as an actor
yeah he was too crazy he was trying to
be more serious when you submitted by
SunChips our trash your [ __ ] trash
you piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] oh you just
offended David wait SunChips our trash
that's the name of him I guess it took
me a while to get into SunChips not
really you are trash you piece of [ __ ]
and I hope that you lay down in front of
a car to survive the car driving and
running over you but you still survive
that's pretty bad names all of your
limbs but you survived yeah I sound
dried tomatoes on trips ooh those are
good mom hey ranch
anyways a woman will be jailed for 10
years after making a series of false
rape claims hell yeah she should be a
jail for life are they gonna get him
give her that exactly know it depends on
how rich you are when you get tried as a
guy I say she should be hiding anything
because she [ __ ] up twice right so
number one you're trying to [ __ ] up the
that one dude's life and number two
you're [ __ ] up for women out there
let me do it
is it wrong to think that if she's gonna
be charged with falsifying the rape that
she should actually get raped there's a
thing we have unfortunately in the
Constitution - bummer
it's called cruel and unusual punishment
oh I think it's actually Bill of Rights
not Constitution but yeah it's a bummer
you guys know the secret right like if
you if you ask for and if you intend for
it and you hope for it and you keep
telling people like yes one day I'm
gonna be rich or whatever it's gonna
come to you well so if she goes to
prison it probably will have I for
enough he's gonna get hairbrush really
not
yes I'm saying God uses objects like a
broomstick hmm yeah or they fingerblast
are too hard that's true yeah she's dry
but not that I'm wishing this happens
I'm just you know my brains going to
boom I for an I type of place I always
go out for a night always it's great
it's a great place to be mentally I
think good for my good for my psyche
good for my mentality I think yeah it's
soothing to the soul you know like some
people like like listening to Sade and
light enough candles me I like to
listening to huh hmm oh
jerking off watching death wish
absolutely hey dude an eye for an eye is
the greatest song I've ever had where
the candle for my friend yeah I mean we
use it some people like to light candles
yeah listen to ya like jazz or some
soothing soul music and I'm over here
imagining ways of how to get people back
yeah have an adventure dude I love
nothing more in the world I'm like the
best revenge is success people who say
that clearly have not smash somebody's
tell us what they have room for there's
two kinds of people two kinds of people
that like to destroy and the kind of
people that like to hug and love comes
out in how you handle your alcohol if
you're a hugger when you a drink oh
you're totally a hugger it's you know
drunk all right drunk hmm sober minds
yeah what if I don't even go there and I
just puke that's who you are
just Bobby just get thrown away yeah so
this woman her name is Gemma she's 25
years old from London hmm she has been
found guilty of four counts of perjury
and four counts of perverting the course
of justice and so she will be jailed for
10 years her name is Gemma yep
on the show sons of anarchy there's a
lady named Jenna mom that's also played
by the mom that was married with
children
Steven Seagal white no she's uh no no no
she's she's uh what's his name the guy
that played Otto he's also a famous guy
but I'm gonna show sons of anarchy
yeah what's your point he's on the phone
my mom right now but gemma is always
causing trouble for the sons of anarchy
and here we have this one and this one
so make sure any girl Gemma except this
one stop girl we work with her name is
Gemma she's [ __ ] cool so she's okay
everybody else I've never known a cool
Gemma also ever and I hope I never do
Gemma is the ugly version of Jenna
[Music]
doesn't feel like that's like a Filipino
name like Filipinos name they're
american-born daughters Gemma I just
could never be friends with somebody
named that something I could so if this
girl did it that she was she claimed
that she had been raped by nine men and
seriously sexually assaulted by 600 I'm
kidding listen what does she look watch
it here picture cuz she's gonna look
nuts I guarantee she looks nuts I bet
you she lost the court case based on her
looks alone oh dude no no joke it's like
jury they all said the officer of the
jury threw up and then they gave her
like I had been raped ten times like you
what if she looks like you know Pam
Anderson or something yeah
I'm being insensitive but if she was
really hot then maybe ten guy was in the
same group or like they're separated it
was always in three years so there were
separate occasions just kept getting
dragged away rape alley like no man ever
gets raped that many times
no yeah by nine different guys right
yeah maybe like Sacagawea
now back in the day you know you don't
mean like in the day there was some [ __ ]
going it's not 1731 he was drunk every
time and she was claiming that you know
cuz like if you are drunk you don't
can't give consent
well apparently uh this was all because
she wanted attention from her girlfriend
so she wanted him to pee or she's bi or
she's gender fluid she's male and she's
having a straight relationship with a
female it's like [ __ ] Sudoku no I
recently heard it's like not all penises
are penises right it's like vaginas can
be penises too and I'm like where she
get raped okay so the first victim was
back in 2010 and so this man is 37 year
old he was actually sentenced to for
seven years right why walk so these guys
that that she claimed raped her they
went to jail for nothing so he actually
served two years in nine months on his
fault oh my gosh she receives fourteen
thousand dollars in criminal injury
compensation so she claimed that she was
raped by him when he had given her a
ride home
why so she just chose some [ __ ]
innocent uber driver or something maybe
she knew him or I mean how do you get a
ride home either you're a taxicab driver
or you kind of know that person or maybe
she met him in a bar
regardless you got to be pretty [ __ ]
crazy though to like know that this man
is going to jail for ten years and you
don't do anything about that and I gotta
say to like I think for me like rape
it's absolutely terrible but if I knew
somebody and you know in a period of
like a year or two she was like I was
raped
okay let's go please I live right again
okay yeah it sounds like maybe you
should stop trying to get this boy like
once you pass like three come on now now
it seems like fake is out is it double
jeopardy if after I'm released from jail
I rape her because
for the first time crime right can't get
charged for the same crime that would be
a now additional crime okay bye then
okay compulsive liars actually start
believing the [ __ ] they say though so
like if she doesn't feel guilty that
this guy got sentenced 10 years she
might have like convinced herself that
it actually happened because she liked
the sympathy so much well yeah and then
she kept doing it so then in 2012 she
claimed that a complete stranger named
know'm he apparently for enough known so
anyways so this guy complete stranger
she claimed that he groped her and then
gang raped her in a parking lot with
other men but apparently there was CCTV
footage that showed a Gemma was actually
attacking him in a bar he ended up
fleeing the country after being charged
with sexual assault he actually got
charged still yeah where is this okay
unbelievable so then in 2013 she claimed
that two men sexually assaulted her
outside of her home and two months later
she claimed to be gang-raped by four men
she identified two of the men but they
were never charged and then so we're
catching on to her but yeah I mean you
see your track record you go Dan you got
raped a lot yeah I mean all of that
crying wolf
all of your string of allegations it
cost police 6400 investigative hours and
over 320 thousand dollars and like
that's insane that's like very I think
that's their special like police yeah I
mean that's what I always see in the
movies they got a guest come out
so regular voice that my sister spice is
mi5 is there in CIA right yeah my five
is our FBI mi6 is there CAA
oh well anyways what happened to my one
two three and four didn't talk about
their meter maids then I'll talk about
but what about Scotland Yard is that
just police thing yeah these just police
okay yeah so then continuing with the
story
apparently the ex her ex-girlfriend went
to police and said that she was just
making up these allegations and that she
would come up with these when she was
drunk and she would fight with her
girlfriend so thanks a lot ex-girlfriend
after five guys and like something later
you finally come out and this was like I
assume as like a missive where it's like
we're in a fight
here's why I was angry earlier cuz I got
raped this morning or some [ __ ]
like something like that I bet that's a
[ __ ] yeah but it's insane dude I
almost see there we go so this is Gemma
and this is oh she looks like she looks
like she's the one that does the raping
you know that you know when they have
NFL games in Seattle every time they cut
to that [ __ ] they cease I see somebody
like that throw on a fish to some other
guy every time dude
trust me like the b-roll yeah the view
of the city I like the city there was
like your hair at the beautiful famous
Honolulu even accuse somebody of raping
that and first of all I'm just I could
call I could talk about it cuz she's a
piece of [ __ ] you know I'm just saying
that crazy [ __ ] now I am just saying
though if somebody raised some money
this size maybe they've earned it cuz
that is a task I don't know I don't know
she looks like me on a Sunday morning
and everything
like a scared version of you yes exactly
she kind of looks stronger dude no
offense she like if I tried to rape her
I think I was yo you got to see this one
it kind of pictured no no no like I feel
like I would turn around and become the
victim like I would get yeah there's no
[ __ ] up not to say that if you're a
big girl you can't get raped
no she's strong she looks strong she
looks like a wrestler we're just
laughing at her because it's not true
but if it were true it would not be
funny I'd be like a I'd be like a
dachshund trying to [ __ ] a pit bull I
just want to see the noises that come
out of those things I want to see the
guy who got put away for three years and
like wizzy pee-wee Herman sized I mean
is he sitting in the chair at court and
like his legs don't even touch the
ground I do like you viciously raped
this woman you attacked her you piece of
[ __ ] you piece of human waste and he's
just like I didn't do it he's barely in
the chair at all is it how do you get
charged for something just based off of
someone saying like don't quote she was
really convincing these false
allegations of rape false allegations
which will inevitably be widely
publicized are likely to have the
perverse impact of increasing the
likelihood of guilty men going free such
as this bring a real risk that a woman
who has been raped or sexually assaulted
may not complain to the police for fear
of not being believed yet so it's like
this [ __ ] is just making it harder for
women that are actually being she's on
let's see over here we have this thing
called beyond a reasonable doubt at
least as a possible shield against [ __ ]
like this but then like Nicki was saying
sometimes you can't yeah because well
there's a problem with the back the like
the backlog of all the rape kits or
whatever but she probably maybe she did
like have sex with them and then they
had a shame that's why they were able to
actually don't put him in jail but it
was like making a murder guy oh yeah
when I'm away for 18 years off the fake
rape allegations yeah yeah sure but the
first you up but I'm saying that has to
do with if you're rich or poor because
then there's that swim guy that Olympian
swimmer guy in college that had like so
much evidence that he raped this girl oh
my and he got three months in like
community service or whatever
well that was justified because he's a
real clean-cut looking kid yeah exactly
I mean that [ __ ] was nothing to do with
money and if you're getting charged for
rape this the first guy probably didn't
have that much money so the more the
story happens you have you're rich you
can rape yes if you can hire Johnny
Cochran okay yep
okay but don't do it guys okay guys
would you think of that video I know you
loved it so make sure to hit that like
button to watch more videos and check it
out up here
[Music]
[Music]